guys look better in a suit it's
form-fitting it's official like and when
you do like a perk of doing a late night
show is that they give you expensive
beautiful suits that you look better
than you normally would they put makeup
on you you look better than you normally
would they shoot you straight on I have
like no chin I've had posture but when
you sit at a desk that's that's me at my
best
no I didn't have that with this show
it's that's a good point like there's
something so nice about when you do a
show
you will look your best and you just
show up and they just get throw you an
outfit and you don't like think about it
and they just would you leave the makeup
on after you would leave studio and just
kind of like would you take that stuff
off I would I would usually take it off
because I feel like people know if you
go and grab drinks and then you have a
little bit of makeup on they're like you
made a choice like yeah I can't pull off
thing like I just ran out so quickly so
let's just have drinks it's like no
you're the guy who came to drinks
wearing makeup we know you had a moment
where you could have taken it off so I
always take it off can't take it off
Jordan no you I think you should use it
because men do look better with makeup
or it would behoove you to wear some
stuff not use but general you you for
sure well yeah I could
[Music]
I would look weird to around the beard a
beard I think they could because it
would just be here would be great and
then this would be because you
don't know how to put on makeup like if
you knew how to put it on like you can
do anything with makeup its Kimmel wears
makeup and he has a beard I had a couple
chairs that I was holding and my skin
would move from the pole like it was do
you remember your first chin hair like
is it like a thing for a woman she
framed it yeah no it's not do you
remember your first genera I remember
getting a little mustache around your
cheeks so excited do you remember your
first hair that got close to your eye do
I have one that's always the fear you
have to draw the line with the yeah
beer but then sometimes there's that
because you know I have cut it's gonna
come back longer is this giant fear and
then like that weird hair that gets
closer and closer to your eye and you're
like oh no am I gonna happy a guy with
like eye hair men are so mysterious
[Laughter]
those things sprout overnight like
cactus and Santa Fe how did this get
there who has seen it who's encountered
it who sucked on it sometimes I just
take a handful and I just grab whatever
might be there and I just grab around my
nipple and rip and get them all out and
sometimes there's nothing there but you
just don't know they grow so fast Jordan
Klepper 'he's here now I know that
nipple hair is essentially like a
succulent the new show is Klepper it's a
new documentary series debuts again this
thursday set your DVRs for Klepper
you're out on the field you're talking
up to activist
is that is that the conceit of the show
essentially we kind of wanted to go to
like the frontline of activist movements
and some of those are quite literally
people who are tying themselves to
pipelines to get their stuff but some of
them are undocumented students are
trying to go to college some of them are
more personal battles where it's it's
people fighting PTSD and their own
demons and so kind of the idea was let's
go to people who are doing something
yeah I just throw money at things that I
care about like that's convinces me
enough like oh I'm doing something but
like the people that the people I throw
money at like the I do a lot of animal
rescue at animals they don't know what
to do but I often say this like it's
that's so easy to do compared to what
the people that I'm giving the money to
go in and see and they go into these
they find these dogs that are abused and
they see the things that I'm just like I
don't want to see it I'm so in awe of
activist and I just don't know that I
have it in me and I wish I would what
did you are you inspired by them too
oh yeah I mean I I'm right along with
you on that I think this was sort of an
opportunity of like live in New York I
also I will donate I care well I like
living in New York I like commenting
from New York a lot of people we know or
coming in from coasts on what's going on
and so this was eye-opening I think like
a lot of the humor comes from me I'd
like to think of myself as a kind of a
good guy yeah but it's hard to go out
and make change happen and so you give
all of these people credit even people I
don't agree with like they're out there
pounding the pavement they're putting
their money where their mouth is and
it's tough and it sucks sometimes you're
stuck in the middle of the Bayou I'm
surrounded by mosquitoes eating gruel
being chased by police
what is that what happened there so I
there was there's pipeline protesters in
the middle of Louisiana who are trying
to stop the pipeline coming through them
they hide out at a special camp they're
environmentalists there's a group that
there is they're called pipeline jumpers
who essentially go to other pipelines
from like Dakota access all the way now
down to this baiyu bridge pipeline we
met up with them a top-secret location
of Louisiana and they take you to there
[Laughter]
right now is a very big city at least
200 people yeah get out now guys I'm
sorry I blew your cover that's the
second stop sign you've gone too far
we spent a couple days we slept outside
with these activists they wake up in the
middle of the night they drive an hour
and a half into the Bayou which is very
remote we got on boats and with the idea
of arriving at the construction site
before the workers got there and they
wanted to tie themselves to the pipeline
and your makeup is on we get in there we
travel for the hour in the Bayou seeing
crocodiles it's 4:35 a.m. we get passed
by a police boat the police boat starts
to give chase from us it causes a wake
we turn back into that it sinks our
boats what we sink in the Bayou I have
to grab all the equipment that's
floating with the the Crocs that are all
around there I grab the equipment we
swim to shore we throw the equipment up
there and we wait yes it's like active
croc yeah yeah this is it's honestly
weird literally we're in the bayou and
we're they're afraid of police coming
because they don't want to get harassed
by police guys you're with the guys we
were with Botes sunk we tried to get the
boat out but the boat is Sun and so we
are hanging out in the woods cop boats
are coming and we're ducking because
they're afraid of also people from the
pipeline they have their own private
security they're coming into the woods
and so our guys are all dressed up in
camo they have machetes out there and
I'm like what the this is not where
I want to be I get credit but like the
detective ISM is hard we realize you're
like what am I doing here how is this
gonna end is this
even worth it good is this an act - is
this an act 3 you know does it feel fake
like do you feel the intensity of it or
do you feel like I'm shooting a show so
it's not really gonna like get to me you
feel the intensity I think and I I will
say quite honestly in making this show
like we had to strip away some of the
joking this because of that because the
stories actually became much more
compelling than like the the wry ironic
sense of humor that like I've done with
The Daily Show and stuff like this but
once you're there with these folks for
three days you're literally sinking
boats and afraid that you could get
arrested and/or burned by cops
yeah like suddenly you loot you drop all
of that you're like well we're making a
documentary now this isn't just me
making jokes and so that's sort of what
the show became there's like let's go to
these places let's let's I will find
ways to find humor there but what these
people are doing is serious some are
doing it better than others and we try
to comment on that but it's legitimate
let's try to cover the legitimate stuff
and find the comedy on the back end so
cool these people that tie themselves to
stuff to prevent trees from being did or
the pipeline did they tighten did you
see them did they tie themselves to the
thing they don't get to that point they
were supposed to but because of the
sinking that they called it all off they
would to go so yeah so it blew
everything which also I was a little bit
scared of seeing you know this and there
was talk of whether or not I should be a
part of it which was a weird sketch or
like I'm here to kind of Chronicle what
you guys do you should lock yourself to
this pipeline yeah be my trailer yeah
we're gonna see soldiers dealing with
PTSD and you went and documented that
what did you find there how do you make
that funny and was that hard to do yes I
think what was good about this story was
they were finding a positive way of
dealing with a tough issue PTSD and so
they're like we professional wrestling
as bad guys we put paint on our faces
and we go out there we body slam one
another and I was like cool can we talk
about that yeah and they're remarkably
open guys who are like I had big
assumptions about wrestling
and just this over masculine culture and
they're so open about the issues that
they're dealing with like mr. stud
tacular is one of the guys who homeless
got his penis shot off in Iraq so he
came back and was like I need to have
kids because everything is fleeting so I
could bring them into a world where
dicks get shot off exciting stuff and
but like there's such compelling guys
and talk about like the difficulties of
dealing with PTSD you got to find
community you've got to find an outlet
and this is something you didn't know
about PTSD because I feel like we all
like grasp like oh if there's like a
door slamming they're gonna freak out
and jump under a bed or it's like and
obviously it's much more than that but
as is was there anything about it that
you were like oh I didn't know there was
an I took there's a writer named
Sebastian Junger who talks a little bit
about veterans coming back from war he
talks about a lot of them saw trauma
many people are coming back with PTSD
who didn't see active combat and they
still have PTSD and a thing that I'm
from like the culture that they're
living in
and then they're also coming back to a
culture and he points out like some
people are receiving PTSD through the
re-entry into American culture which is
one without community it's without
connection it's very solo on your phones
and like just the experience of being a
marine is one of like you're with a
group you're not talking about politics
you're talking about caring for the
group and then you come back to a
country where it's like we don't do the
group thing anymore also pick a side
you're either the left or the right and
I think that can be that can be so
discombobulating for a lot of folks yes
I just actually got stopped on the
street last night by a girl who listens
to the show and listened to me talk
about depression and like anxiety and
all the things we're dealing with and
she was she's a fan of the show and
she's a comedian name's Lynette I
believe and she stopped me she was
barking people into a show on the street
which is when you you just ask people to
do you like live comedy come see the
show and she I go I do like life coming
she goes I know you she was oh my god
I've been meaning to tell you about this
book called tribe that I think you'll
love that's Sebastian yoghurts book
really so you okay that's so crazy
because it's exactly what you're saying
is that we are used to being in tribes
like that's as a
human we're supposed to have this sense
of community and be among other people
and we're not anymore because we're all
on our phones and so we're depressed and
then when you're depressed what do you
know you don't want to be around people
so it's you just get into this this trap
of isolating yourself with only makes it
worse so like yeah that did you have any
anything uh I didn't even I just heard
this girl told me about this book is
that you heard about a book yeah they
start conversations it is that we are
like we're really struggling as a nation
because we're we're all in our phones I
and we're we just don't have a sense of
community 100% that book does look at
like historically this is always
something that we are tribal by nature
like even it breaks down like we do best
in tribes of almost like 30 where we can
have an identity within it but also the
group can look out for one another that
we missed this he is a war journalist so
a lot of it looks at like people coming
back from overseas and and that was what
was most compelling to me he was like
human beings need basic things which is
like self-worth feeling like they're
needed that they're accepted and what
they do matters and you need a community
to kind of reinforce those things and
that he talks a lot about the depression
that troops see but he connects it to it
matches a lot of depression we are all
seeing right now and he's like again I
thought the thing that was a little bit
was it was fresh and new was this idea
that a lot of the PTSD people are
discovering is not necessarily the
battles that are happening overseas
those are happening of course but they
are the re-entry into a culture that is
just divided and not communal that is
wild that that is what would cause the
PTSD but I do know that a good
supplement for being in a tribe is just
getting a tribal tattoo I feel like that
does give you that sense of covered by
barbed wire it's protected protected
tribalism
yeah well this right I've started a
program to give vets tribal tattoos more
tribal tattoo
[Laughter]
that's so what I wanted to ask you about
you know you had a show that was on TV
four nights a week and you did it for a
really long time what is it like for you
to be out of that combat zone and
re-entry into the world like what I mean
that was us that was a grind it was a
grind it's it's it's so many things that
I loved it but it's uh it's overwhelming
I mean you're you you never stopped
thinking and you're never stopped you're
consistently plugged into the the tweet
cycle the everything cycle and so I was
I was up at 5:00 binging news stressed
all day doing the show doing the show
and then up reading news and that was
just that was like a seven day a week
kind of a thing and part of that is even
like talking to other late night hosts
who were living a similar schedule
everybody had that same or story of like
it's a year and a half before you even
know what the rhythm of the show is it's
years until you feel comfortable doing
that and especially in this day and age
where everybody's connected to the the
Trump cycle like things have suddenly
gotten even different and more ramped up
which adds more obligation but also less
insight because everybody's nibbling on
the same ridiculous tweet and so to be
pulled out of that the first thing is
relief there actually gets to be depth
of thought on a couple things here and
they're like I'm not gonna read those
tweets I'm gonna read an entire article
and what have you and so or a thread or
thread yeah these things where a guy
will write more has a certain amount of
character and threads yeah it's pretty
it's it's like it's more of like a
weekly show the thread essentially what
was your first week of like not having
the show like did you go on vacation
what did you do to celebrate freedom
from that grunt I went on vacation I
would I went to Italy which was amazing
I had had the trip
already planned it was like went to
Italy and lived that Italy life
I bought Italy clothes I I do I do like
working yes
was there any uncomfortableness not
having that grinded oh I mean there's
always just like what do I do now yes
there's always fear for for all of that
and I think like the benefit of a job
like that is structure and what I'd love
about the daily shows like that is a
structured day every 10-15 minutes and
that's so exhausting but it's so nice
and like you know what you're doing it
every you know what you're doing and
also it's it's it builds up to something
that's wonderful like it's great being
out in the road and it's I think better
for my life and it's so many new
experiences doing doing yeah but I even
like a month into Klepper I had like
this this sadness that was there it was
like I you know I really love doing this
but what am I missing and you think back
of it it is the suits and the makeup and
it's every day ends with an audience
listening to jokes that have been been
worked on for a day on a teleprompter
the audience is told to like laugh and
enjoy it and then you leave you're like
a product of the day at the end of every
day there's a product whereas when
you're out on the road making the show
you're like what is this even gonna look
like I can't visualize yet and there's
not that sense of accomplishment that
you get from doing a daily show there's
no audience there's no finish line which
is which is a benefit as far as creation
goes but as far as like affirmation of
what you're doing which i think is
comedians you consistently want and I'm
yeah I don't have that audience like the
it so it's like exactly but it is a
tribe Daily Show was a tribe for you and
now you're out on your own with these
divisive but you're explaining exactly
you're explaining exactly what the
soldiers went through well I mean I
think that meeting a dick shot off
exactly the world the competitive world
of satirical a bad comedy
exactly but I do think that yeah no but
what you are explaining that you do have
that sense of group and like that self
more about a show a show ends I've had
two shows cancelled that is the thing
that I missed the most is like the team
and like the Saint you see the same
people every day and you're in it
together and it is like your troop yeah
Oh a hundred percent that's that's the
big I mean when you tell that staff that
like oh we're done working in a couple
weeks it's heartbreaking and you realize
it is it's like oh I love doing that
show that show I'm proud of it loved it
but it is it's the people it's the
people you hang out with every day it is
family you so you don't get those
communities very often and as you get
older like they become farm for you
between and so to create a space that is
people you like people who are funny
people are inspiring like that that's a
big loss
wait now when you were on the road did
you have you had producers and people
that you could count on every day to be
like your point people and like keep you
sane you weren't just out there by
yourself but it could it was probably a
little bit isolating you'd go back to
the hotel room at night after having
seen what you saw during the day I mean
what was that like it is like we travel
light but we're using with a couple
camera guys sound guy and a producer
following through and so like you become
close-knit but but it's a straight like
you're I'm in Killeen Texas had a weird
LaQuinta like talking to vets all day
which honestly is i opening you have
these big experiences out there and then
you're going back prepping for the next
day working out of weird little holiday
ends all across the country and like
again you do feel like you are in it and
you're you're you're stumbling on more
compelling stories that you wouldn't get
elsewhere but you're tired and you're
it's it's not glamorous I mean I think
we are all together we worked out it for
around eight months Wow I had some
answers because some of these each
episode we're we're embedding for like a
week with people and then also the ebb
and flow of booking gets really
difficult because we wanted to be with
there when you're going out when an
action has happened when when an event
is there so it's not just retelling up
stories it's like I want to be there
when a story takes place so so you're
like on your you're on your you're
waiting for a story to come through and
then suddenly - and then you're gone for
a month filming and then you're in the
Edit trying to piece it all together
you're doing comedy but you're a legit
journalist like living like him we got
arrested less as a journal more as a
freedom fighter is sort of how I don't
call myself the daily showing on your
show we're just always so strong you
talking to people is like you have just
such a talent for it you make people
feel at ease I mean you walk in here and
I'm like always nervous to have someone
in that's promoting a show cuz I want to
do a good job but you just put me at
ease immediately you're a friendly guy
you're so funny I'm really excited about
this show because that is just I love
watching you in that element and the
show again is Klepper it debuts this
Thursday and sign up for a season pass
on your DVR you're gonna watch this show
you're gonna love it you're gonna learn
something and you're gonna laugh a lot
you on this show yeah okay you know I
mean you getting arrested I bet you were
pretty devastated but like do you don't
want a record or were you like this is
cool this honestly it was it was a
pretty life-changing moment like I was I
was nervous about crossing the line of
like I want to cover these stories but I
don't want to be like the activist for
every story that lays very limiting and
also I think instance here but this one
was these are undocumented daca students
who just want to go to college and home
this was like a lot of people I would
meet along the way and you can joke
about stuff but the thing that kept
being thrown at me was you got a
weaponize your privilege like we could
joke about the fact but you're a white
guy with a TV show and you're talking
about Native American issue
great let's find humor in this but like
understand that you have a little bit of
power and a light that you're shining so
use that and I think like when you go
down to meet students like that and they
kind of are looking for a voice this
thing happened where it was like I can
kind of stand up with these other faith
leaders who stood up and protested
trying to bring light so it was like I
think I'm really doing this yeah and I
will say what an amazing thing that
happened I'm I'm an atheist I have been
I've been grumpy about religion for a
long time but you go down to Atlanta I
spend time with these these students and
the other people who were there to
support them were faith leaders they
were pastors around town because they
grew up in civil rights era Atlanta they
know the history there and they're like
the purpose of the church is to be a
community where we can be a tribe and to
push forward for rights for people don't
have them which is a new respect for
faith leaders that I hadn't had and then
as I'm getting arrested I spent 12 hours
in jail with Pastor Matt who was my
grandmother's pastor 10 years earlier in
Kalamazoo Michigan who I met 10 years
earlier my grandma was like let's bring
my little atheist grandson in to meet
pastor Matt he's our new Kalamazoo
Congregational Church pastor he's great
and I'm like who is this guy
10 years later he's bounced around from
church to church he's found this cause
and I was like this I need to stand up
for this we spend the day in jail
talking with Pastor man about my grandma
so so any moment in my head that's like
is this the right thing to do I'm like
yeah grandma told me so 10 years ago so
you you have a record now I do yes so
what was that like getting like
handcuffed and booked and all that
what's that traumatizing it was I felt I
was with people who had it had happened
before and they're like this is how it
works and so it's nerve-wracking you get
thrown in a car all of those all of
those things you hear are true we're in
a holding cell for holding you they
bounce you around they get you in there
and you do the strip search the COFF
thing right yeah you bend over like
honestly it's it's the first thing you
hop on a little paddy wagon well if they
throw you in the back of a car and I do
not fit is that when you recognize
pastor
[Laughter]
so yeah they'd walk you in and you they
Lydon you all up and there's a guy who's
an enviable job is like alright you come
on over here they open up a door you go
around the corner you take up the
clothes and I'm just watching everybody
hand they're close to this guy who sets
it aside and then there's they ask you
to coughed Weiss to squat and cough
twice it's so funny because I literally
watching this helping a person after
person yeah there's no no even dreaming
about them making sure you didn't ever
weapon up your butt no they make you
cough so that anything would like come
out of your ass
but what if your ass is super tight the
- coughing is industry standard is what
you find out like it's just - and then
it's so so if you can withstand - coughs
then you're fine okay that's that's so
scary
it's very strange I yeah you're watching
that happen I'm coughing and then I'm
then you're bounced around I'm in a Cell
honestly it's like the premise of a bad
joke I'm not like an atheist in a cell
with five pastors for like three hours
and then they bounced me around and then
at one point somebody comes in they're
like do the television show I'm like I
do but I want to stay here the way we're
told to bring you to another cell and so
I'm like I'm staying with them but like
you need to come with me and they take
me to another cell I'm like well I'm in
my own cell fine this what it is you
know I'm kind of VIP they don't want me
in with general population like a half
hour 40 photos later they come back to
lay you're fine we're just gonna put
your back yeah we googled the raid in
season one
[Music]
just put him back with everybody we're
gonna switch Jordan Klepper thank you so
much for being here the new show is
Klepper a comedy central thursdays 10:30
p.m. Eastern you gotta you got a DVR
this show now watch it live on Thursday
give it good ratings cuz this deserves
it I can't wait to see this show I love
a good documentary style show we're
gonna learn something
you're always so funny out in the field
I'm so excited about this Jordan thank
you for being thanks for having me
thanks for sharing all those stories if
you're gone yeah you put your gum here
you're fine with it
yeah I'm fine it looks cool you're
closer to me
[Music]
I need stevia I forgot to put the CV in
my coffee and I'm literally depressed
because of it
you're always so nice to me before you
drink your coffee No
are you treat me very bad before you
have your coffee I think that that's not
true I think I treat you bad all the
time that's true
but especially before you had your
coffee and your four stevia your almond
milk it did it no it's not I didn't
order the right thing and it's it's
wrong and now I'm upset but it's like
life is pretty good no doubt bro then
you read that on a bumper sticker Oh
life is pretty good just give me a
coffee and some tunes I am one of those
people that like before I've had my
coffee
I'm not pleasant to be around and I
never wanted to be one of those like
don't talk to me till I've had my
caffeine but I should wear one of those
shirts yeah but have it say Andrew well
I think that is you that really gets on
my nerves before I've had my coffee oh
you don't think it has anything to do
with the coffee no my addiction to
caffeine has nothing to do with the fact
that I'm irritated before I have the
thing that I only wake up thinking about
and go to sleep what is it what is it
about my face that makes you so angry
it's not your face it's your overall
demeanor yeah what is it it's that
you're just you get to just show up
through life and like and things are
just taken care of for you and you just
there doesn't seem to be a lot of hustle
there's more like just yeah you just
swipe like you're just sitting in a
chair like this like hey and you're here
you got here you took a train you woke
up yeah a lot of work went into that
mm-hmm but I just you represent men to
me yeah and I take it out on you yeah I
feel that yeah I'm sorry even though I
don't do anything to deserve that
it's not even men that like
I haven't called me or don't want to
bang me it's like mmm another sip keep
going I think you mean it's burning it's
burning maybe you need that come on
now do you feel better did you get your
coffee
Oh your one-shouldered backpack is
really annoying me well you you think
it's gonna look not cool enough with two
shoulders look Pamela likes it like that
my eighth-grade girl no now I do she's
cool
hey guys you just watch the clip for my
radio show you up with Nikki Glaser that
you can hear every morning on comedy
central radio sirius XM channel 95 10:00
to 12:00 eastern and you can check out a
clip here on youtube every tuesday or
check out my podcast no